this morning our real food series looks
at the rise of the organic food industry
more people are willing to pay premium
prices for food grown without pesticides
or synthetic fertilizers that's despite
the fact that the science behind the
purported health benefits remains
unsettled Amy's kitchen is one of the
pioneers of the organic food movement
the company's revenues reportedly around
half a billion dollars a year founders
Rachel and Andi Berliner rarely do
interviews but they recently sat down
John Blackstone who among other things
wanted to know if there is a real Amy at
the end of a dirt road in the heart of
California's wine country sits in 1870s
farmhouse we used to have our sales
meetings in the barn when we were small
this is where Rachel and Andy Berliner
cooked up Amy's kitchen helping to
pioneer the organic food movement the
ranch still serves as the corporate
headquarters nothing miraculous about
what we do we just do it a simple
old-fashioned way somebody's hungry I
want to feed them I could be in a
meeting and I hear so in the background
oh I'm really hungry
also excuse me I've got to go feed this
person today they make more than 250
different products most of them frozen
all of them organic Amy's kitchen
prepares about a million frozen meals a
day yet burritos are still rolled by
hand the Berliners believe it tastes
better that way but organic food was
rare back in the 1980s when they began
this all started in places like Portland
and San Francisco two decades later we
suddenly think hey maybe those people
are onto something it may have started
as a small movement but by 2016 the
organic food industry had grown into a
forty seven billion dollar business to
be certified organic by the USDA food
must be free of synthetic additives like
pesticides and chemical fertilizers and
cannot be genetically modified final
products must contain at least 95%
organic ingredients my parents had a
organic garden in LA in the 50s and they
taught me to always eat healthy and to
never eat things I couldn't pronounce
the first well here along with healthy
eating Andy and Rachel remember too
feed the soul they met on a spiritual
retreat in India you still kind of
hippies at heart when Rachel was
pregnant in 1987 they looked for organic
food that was fast and easy when they
couldn't find it they decided to go into
business making an organic tofu potpie
this is the kitchen where it all began
is the table where we do all our tasting
ever since the family kitchen has been
at the center of their business the
tastings are right here in this kitchen
it's still done the same way we've
always done it as the company grew so
did their daughter you are Amy yes I am
Amy Amy is well-aware parents legacy is
in her hands there has to be a big
temptation to just cash in it's a huge
company you've had offers just sell it
and not worry about working another day
in your life yeah we could just solve
the company and be multi Multi multi
millionaires but the reality is this is
something my parents have always taught
me is that happiness does not come from
money happiness comes from meaning and
purpose well they've never spent a dime
on advertising their brand has become a
fan favorite on social media that's
helped sales of frozen entrees rise by
more than 70 percent in the past four
years and with the appetite for organic
growing and 2015 they opened their first
fast food vegetarian drive-through it
stays busy even with several burger
chains nearby talk about a risk that was
a real risk I still had trouble
visualizing people coming to an organic
vegetarian directory and they just I
think many people and they were lined up
around the block when we opened so
you've been in the right place at the
right time yeah we've stumbled well
Amy's kitchen is now a frozen food
Empire guided by Rachel and Andy simple
recipe just do what you love for CBS
this morning John Blackstone Petaluma
California and the food is really
delicious it's a good way to get rich
find out where your passion is and what
you want to do and that's all
and let the money come later